okay so today we're reading another
platonic dialogue and this one's called
the Euthyphro just like the credo it's
named after the guy who decides is
talking to this guy's a bit different
than credo is saggin is dead right this
is actually right before Socrates goes
into his famous trial which is gonna be
the last law case you ever gets involved
in credo is a friend of Socrates
Euthyphro seems to be a friend of
Socrates - all right they know each
other I was used to from different from
credo in your interview they read both
of the dialogues if you had to describe
two different do you know anybody like
him
it seems to be driving how do you think
he's better than pretty much everybody
else because he says it doesn't I know
more about this than everybody else does
yeah that's that's a very important part
so yeah he thinks this goes back to the
credo doesn't it because in the creative
Socrates is concerned with who actually
knows about these things that many don't
know about these things you know as
Euthyphro doesn't doesn't like the many
either does he who says the many others
are full of it they think they know
about all this sort of stuff I know
about this stuff and yeah he thinks he
knows what's right and wrong and he
thinks he knows it so well he's actually
gonna prosecute his own father case
pretty unheard of we do that sort of
thing
right now there were some I'll talk
about why there were some definite
reasons what you wouldn't do that sort
of thing back in ancient Greece it's not
just right and wrong though what else
does he think he knows better about than
anybody else
what's the dialogue about what's the key
thing hi yeah now that's not a word that
we use a lot of business or being the
answer to that we use is being pious and
the opposite is impiety have any of you
ever said you know somebody is pious or
talked about piety in your life up to
this point you use that word before you
haven't used that word but you've used
that concept what do you think it's
close to that we would say in our only
unholiness now if we put it like that
Euthyphro thinks he knows more about
what it means to be holier than thou
everybody's got some sort of relative or
friend or acquaintance who leaves
themselves much closer to God and to
have a much better idea about what's
Holy Ones funnel be what God likes from
what God doesn't like than the rest of
us
and they may in fact couldn't that could
be true maybe they actually do you know
I mean you know we recognize certain
people as particularly good guides in
that respect thinking about mothers
recently died one two three years ago
she was considered pretty holier right
if you ask somebody who's a saint
she's one of the first people that they
tend to name and what made her you know
what made her holy she seemed to be a
been a good lady she did some good stuff
right what'd she do
should make a lot of money on Wall
Street and then give it over the floor
know what did she do something in India
right
what does India have a lot of besides
you know say elephants poor people and
poverty in India means being desperately
poor yeah I mean we need to have this
poverty index in the United States
there's big news because the poverty
index is you know there's more people in
poverty in the United States than ever
before but you know like people who put
it up being poor in the Unites States
means you still have an air conditioner
in a car and a TV and a game you know
console of some sort just means you
don't have as much stuff as there are
some people who are desperately before
the United States but not so much as in
India and she took care of that the ones
who were poor and who were sick and the
ones who were dying who people thought
they're not good for anything why why
even waste time up there dying why not
help all these other people over here in
people look to that and they said that's
a holy woman that's that's somebody who
is in touch with what does it mean that
equally it means something having
something to do with with God right if
you say somebody's holy you don't just
mean that they read the Bible a lot you
mean that they read the Bible a lot and
presumably because of that they know
something about God maybe they don't
read the Bible a lot but they
they practice what are called the
virtues you know the theological virtues
like faith and hope and love or charity
presumably that tells them something
about God that makes them closer
together
how is Euthyphro he's not very much like
Mother Teresa is he
do you think of anybody he's like in
your experience anybody in our culture
we do have a lot of people who think
they know an awful lot about what God
wants both of you know the right and the
left and then they talk about it a lot
sometimes they'll say things like you
know God wants you to vote Republican
God once you're more Democrat how do
they know that
get out I don't see that anywhere in
Scripture
God wants you to be nice to people
gods for gay marriage God's like God's
against gay marriage people argue both
sides of that don't they they're very
often they they see themselves the way
you did fro does the other people they
don't know what they're talking about I
do I'm the one who's who's holding so
that's this guy Uther prose character he
you know when he's fitting what Plato
wants he Plato doesn't want you look to
the money he wants you to you know stand
out to think about things yourself does
you throw think a lot about things
to make it a constant practice where is
he getting us at where does he get his
first ideas about what's holy and what's
not one day from before we get into all
the arguments how does he know that
prosecuting his own father's the right
thing to do
you don't have to raise your hands you
can just say you know shout it out if
you want to what do you remember this
what does he say I'm doing this and I
know it's right because the right
masseuse yeah
yes Zeus did the same thing if you know
your ancient Greek mythology Zeus is dad
was another God and his dad Kronos had
another day and who else was a god and
they were all being guns who rhinos
trying to you know destroy it and all
those children
Colonels trying to destroy his children
they're very savage there's a whole
story about this and Zeus ends up having
to you know take action against his own
father well you know that makes us sound
like that's the right thing to do right
I mean if the gods are yeah then why
shouldn't you do it most of the Greek
gods do that might be a little
questionable in our time can anyone
remember but even if you even if you
think about movies maybe haven't read
most of the male gods she done on their
spouses Zeus is the worst one of all
where do you think all these demigods
and heroes come from there are the sons
of Zeus for the most part because Zeus
is constantly going around and fighting
some you know some some female human
being that he thinks is attractive and
then getting her knocked up and usually
she doesn't have anything to say about
it you know he appears in all different
forms of golden rain a bowl a swan you
know all these different things this is
this is part of their their mythology
but this was the way they saw the world
and where were they getting this
you know we have the in our culture
which has been formed by by what we call
Abrahamic religions right Judaism
Christianity Islam
there's the holy book for each one of
those there wasn't a holy book for the
Greeks they have all these different
poems and you know hymns and things like
that was kind of a mess he and so
Euthyphro is saying well that's where we
get our ideas about what's holy and
unholy and because Zeus did this to his
own dad it's okay for me to do this
timeline forget what everyone else
thinks about it I know because I had
actually studied these stuff they don't
know that's why they think this was kind
of strange now notice what Socrates says
to Euthyphro this he says how little
does the common herd know of the nature
of right truth the man must be an
extraordinary man ative made great
strides and wisdom before he could have
seen his way to such an action
it's not about Euthyphro doing this
pretty chancy thing of the prosecuting
his father if you were going to do that
sort of thing you really want to be sure
that's it's the right thing so you must
have really made sure that that you know
exactly what the right thing to do is in
this case didn't you use the throne
well of course how does it actually turn
out has he thought any of this through a
lot of head shaking you thought some of
it through is that totally you know
going straight by the seat of the pants
he thought hey there was a principal
here you know somebody committed a
murder
God's heat murder got to prosecute the
murder
I know it's my own dad he tend to do
this but you know it's you know it's
it's pollution to a lot of murders
their myths so the key question that it
starts with is this question about is it
okay to prosecute your father and why is
it when does it come up you know in
terms of piety well in ancient
civilizations really in most
civilizations until modernity parents
were regarded in a different way than
they are by us today you remember when
we were looking at the Credo Socrates
the Oise speak to him almost like a
father would speak to to a sudden they
say I made you I create well the family
and the relationship between father and
son was very asymmetrical so and it
still is in some families today so the
father was way up here and the son is
Wade out of here and that will change
when the Sun becomes grown-up father
later on there's a son
daughters you know at this time this is
a very sex you know segregated society
so daughters almost don't count at all
but the view was that transgressing
against your parents doing something
against your parents was not just
hurting another human being there was
something distinctively panagon so for
instance killing a father killing a
mother that was a worse crime than
killing some some ordinary person on the
street and I wasn't just
father it's because it was felt there
was a sort of a religious impulse to
this he was felt to violate the order of
things
so in prosecuting his father Euthyphro
is doing something very radical and it's
not something that's easy for us to
relate to I mean you can think about
this for example I had actually had to
start thinking about this yes but you
can think about it
now I'm not if you have kids right kids
yeah what if you know I love my my son
and my daughter
what if they committed horrible crimes
this happens there are there there are
cases where somebody seems to be pretty
good and they're loved by people and yet
they do horrific things nice to teach
guys when I was teaching in the prison
what would I get him would I turn her in
my own daughter let's say she lets he
she killed somebody and she didn't just
do it because you know she she was doing
fighting in self-defense or something
like that let's say she had a rival and
her work she just said I'm gonna kill
her let's take care of this person and
she did kill him and then she just
remembered them hit the model swamp and
let's say somebody else found out about
it she killed that person too
so she's killing witnesses that's pretty
bad as what I turn
that's you know that's the sort of
dilemma you don't ever want to have to
face it would be very difficult no
matter which side you choose to feel as
if you're doing the right thing you can
think about this in terms of your own
life let's say your own parents
committed a terrible crime like what
would you do would you say you know I
they're my parents I love them I'm I'm
gonna protect them I'm gonna make sure
that nothing happens I'm gonna keep this
under wraps how many of you would do
that I'm gonna do it turn them in okay
no that's that's fairly your parents
like terrible people like terrible
people do they have a bad track record
this is the second time I've done it
right yeah and you were the victim of
the crime that would be a lot easier to
turn the N different story yeah and you
know actually with with our their legal
system you can sometimes get in trouble
for not turning people reach didn't
quite have yeah but this so these are
all considerations this gives you an
idea but wages so Euthyphro is gonna
make this be about hiding this is the
highest thing to do this is what the
gods want and now the dialog is gonna
shift right Socrates says okay so what
what is piety and I've created like I
said create a little handout for you
with all of arguments in it but let's
look at what the actual words are so
Socrates says it's not pride in every
action the same if we want to say things
about moral values like piety or justice
doesn't it have to be the same thing
in each case doesn't it have to be
consistent impiety is it not always the
opposite so Socrates says can what is
piety and what is impiety tell me what
that is because I don't really know and
then there's you know some background
information to this - right who what's
he being charged with he's being charged
with violating with the religious
conventions by this guy Elena's so he's
kind of playing up you use the front
saying you know you're so smart maybe
you can help me out before I have to go
into court tell me what PI it is so when
I go in there I can say hey I'm okay
I'm pious mellitus he's he's baptized so
what is he with the prosthesis piety is
doing as I'm doing that is to say
prosecuting anyone is guilty of murder
sacrilege or any similar crime whether
he be your father or mother or whoever
he may be
that makes no difference not to
prosecute them as impiety
but we'll what's the sort of clause here
because Socrates is gonna have a problem
with that but let's think about this in
our in our system these days
we're a a nation that you know doesn't
follow there's very few people there
there are two neo-pagans who
experimental following written the
ancient Greek gods but they're you know
the minority of the minority of a
minority what you know what religion is
the most people wanted to hear in this
country
Judaism is one big one in this country
what else Christianity and Christianity
actually Judaism is split over a couple
different you know ways of going about
Orthodox acidic reform
Christianity's went into a whole bunch
of different denominations there are
some really big ones you know Catholics
Baptists Methodists those are the
largest three what else
supposed to be out here in this country
we get into two smaller groups in this
country but it majority is in other
countries yeah Muslims yeah those are
the three big Abrahamic religions
nothing else come in mind my boot is
Hindus right yeah
and now in Hinduism there are a lot of
different gods but they're understood as
being all sort of images of one's once
and alignments yeah you know things of
transportable lines you're not going to
find a lot of Hindus or Buddhists or
Muslims or Christians or Jews saying
it's okay to cheat on your spouse
because the gods do that I can't think
of anybody I know
enable to itself so there's certain
things that the Greeks seem to think
that it was okay because they're guys
what are we in our society what sort of
actions would we say our holy
yeah chance like charities like feeding
yeah every single one of the major
religions teaches that taking care of
the poor or the vulnerable is a
meritorious and I think they've been
playing with the beakers it's kinda nice
to myself yeah Jerry terrible that's a
we differ on aesthetics okay the
beautiful and the ugly we don't quite
agree out of doing just like the credo
Seth yeah I ain't doing charitable
actions what else
yeah going going to church or to mosque
or a synagogue or the temple you know
participating within a community that
seen as being wali
how does religion get mixed up in
politics what was sort of acts or soon
as unholy yeah a lot of some believe
like abortions you're right yeah and
that's one where the Christian churches
are kind of split the the more
traditional conservative churches it's
an abomination its way up there
some of the more liberal churches are
kind of well it's up to the person and
then some are actually letting go but
they're very few of our are pro so yeah
that's what that's an issue
there's a lot of talk during election
years about this is the the right thing
to do because this is what God wants
right what else
gay marriage right New York just passed
a gay marriage bill
some people consider that to be an
abomination if they do it's largely it's
not likely to be based on some sort of
secular morality it's gonna be based on
some sort of religious morality some
idea about what's unholy there's a lot
of things so we have a lot of things we
could relate to it we could give
examples who do you consider to be a
holy person does anybody have sort of a
public figure you could point to and say
I think they're they actually are on the
right track they are in touch with God
some people are shaking their heads do
you think nobody's nobody's a good good
example I mean I I can think of quite a
few but the older you get if you if you
pay attention to your own life and you
look at it very realistically the lower
and lower your your assessment of how
how well you've done with it puts to
have and the more you the more you're
willing to cut people some slack and say
yeah I think they're probably a better
person than I am
anybody who you you'd like to look up to
or let's say you want some advice about
how to get close to God is there anybody
you could go to yeah the priest
hopefully they're a good priest right
I've known some good priests and I've
known some batteries sometimes a bit
priest to become a bad person bad
priests can become a good priest too
well
a lot of people who are holy who are
priests
while what'd you think about that now
what have we done here we've looked at
examples that we defined it slowly do
you have any clearer idea at this point
what actually what being wooly would
consist of something some way to define
it to another person we do have a better
idea
that's okay some of this is supposed to
be puzzling the first a couple of times
around when we just look at examples
this is sort of giving you giving you
the answer as far as Plato Plato is
never for examples he uses a lot of
examples but you'll always say these are
just examples they don't tell you what
the thing actually is so if we want to
know what justice is we don't look at
just one case and play those case we
need some sort of definition we need
some sort of knowledge that could apply
not just in this case but in this case
in this case in this case that's pretty
distinctive to play them and I think
that you know all of you will run into
situations in your life where you're
going to say that to somebody as well
don't just give me some some debt some
examples tell me what you're actually
talking about I don't understand what
you're saying don't you're just throwing
a bunch of examples at me these are
clarifying anything that's what Socrates
is doing so what do they do next
Socrates says I don't want some examples
give me something I can sink my teeth
into
what does either first say hi
we're gonna try a whole bunch of
definitions of what - what does he say
piety is first it's not just doing what
I do it's so what is dear to the guys
now again this is not language that that
we often use in our own speaking
thinking we don't say that's dear to me
do it we might say it's somebody's dear
where we started a letter to your
so-and-so but that's a formality
actually whenever I email you guys I
start off dear so-and-so so I mean that
I hold you in my heart
yeah cherish you really yeah exactly
I just know I just feel you're such good
good well that's not me I can tell you
that right there I use dear and
sincerely as markers here's where I
begin here is where I am right when we
said something's dear we mean what that
we we like it that we approve that we
cherish so what's dear to the gods
what the gods like and again we could
think of examples of the things that
gods likes back in ancient Greece
certain kinds behavior the gods also
liked sacrifices a lot if you read
ancient Greek texts you'll see them
offering you know sometimes you know
small sacrifices sometimes huge
sacrifices there was a word hecatomb
that actually means like a hundred
cattle being sacrificed up at once
Agamemnon actually sacrifices his own
daughter in order to get the ships to be
able to Troy it wasn't happy about but
it did and you know things that the gods
like that's
ss doesn't that sound pretty good that
seems to make sense
alright let's let's put it in
contemporary terms and so does God's God
cuz that's merely how people talk these
days right what's Mullins behaving the
way conflux doing charity right not
lying to me not stealing maybe father
I'm following the Ten Commandments
maybe that's holiness reading the Bible
in time to time or maybe every day
praying you know five times a day or
seven times a day doing a Liturgy of the
hours you know if you really want to be
hardcore there's a problem that the
Greek said that we don't have quite so
much though
what's the problem with Socrates points
out yeah and that's a big problem isn't
it because you know actually again if
you read the ancient Greek stories you
find like at the Trojan War some of the
guys are on one side some of the guys
are on the other side and they're
actually messing around with each other
or if you read The Odyssey how many of
you read The Odyssey okay so who hates a
distance just hates his guts that's okay
who was the guy who hated his guts
remember gather the the see that's why I
took him so long to get back
yes I'm beside it yeah because Odysseus
blinds his son who's a freak
and you know then tells him which was
kind of dumb hey if anything su blinded
you it was a discus and so you know
Poseidon's not happy about that who's
for Odysseus who actually turns out to
there's it's kind of a funny thing she
seems to be in love with the host one of
the goddesses they would know she's kind
of in love with him she also loves his
son not the same kind of way she is by
the way over there you know a maiden god
she doesn't actually Athena so Athena
and Poseidon don't see I am as a matter
of fact Athena tries to trick Poseidon
she waits until he's off somewhere else
and then goes to Zeus and she says hey
what about a distance can we let him
come back yet because she knows that the
sign is on his room because if he was in
the room they would be fighting they
wouldn't agree I mean what are the gods
disagree about remember back to the
credo what do human beings disagree
about these moral values remember what
those we even talked about three ranges
of moral values what were they
two of them were really straightforward
one was a little bit harder to translate
actually Socrates doesn't just say we
disagree about these we actually could
enrich other we do understanding that
for the Greeks this this was kind of
wider that included the beautiful and
the ugly
you know these aesthetic things and do
we disagree about these sort of things
and when we disagree about these things
like Socrates points out are there easy
ways for us to reach agreements on them
we disagree about how many square feet
the room is what can we do and if I
measure it and I you know I come up with
the number that it's like I'm just gonna
guess say 225 square feet and you say
it's 240 and most of you say it's 240
I'm probably wrong aren't I you know
we're fighting measure it I get all
different measures each time I'm
probably wrong there's a way to decide
that is it so easy to decide things when
it's good and evil or just and unjust
let alone ugly and beautiful
and human beings don't agree about these
well the gods don't either
so what are we going to do that this
what's our recourse misters screwed
right we can't we can't decide it off or
kami does Euthyphro think there's a way
out why wouldn't it be a problem in our
societies let's say here you're a Jew or
Muslim or Christian why don't you have
to worry about the fact that the gods
disagree with each other yeah so there's
some sort of consensus because there's
only one I mean with Christian you've
got the Trinity
you know the Father the Son the Holy
Spirit are all on the same page right
there's only one opinion exactly yeah
so maybe we could look at things where
there actually is some consensus like
you know murder yeah all the gods think
murder is bad now does that get you off
you know does that settle all the
disagreements well because we don't
always agree about what counts as murder
in what cases you know think about our
own society you know if I kill somebody
in self-defense some of you would say I
murdered the first and others would say
I did the right thing right let's say
actually let's let's take a case I'm
gonna close this door let's say I find
out that somebody intends to to attack
one here and I'm the only person who can
stop them and I choose to kill them did
I do the right thing or do the wrong
thing some of you would probably say two
wrongs don't make a right
wouldn't you killing is wrong no matter
what someone you would say well this
doesn't actually count as murder it
councilís something else
so it would be solved if I see it when
it's self-defense it seems to be very
straightforward but then it starts to
get stickier the further we get away
from from the self which is why I
brought throwing up that example but
there there could be some things with
the guys all agree stealing even even
you know the Greek god Hermes who is it
got thieves let's say he agrees right so
maybe there are some things that are
dear to all the gods exactly here's
where we get sent some really
interesting stuff this is where we come
to
something that is known use the
provolone and use the pro goes one way
I'm going to introduce a term here that
we haven't actually talked about much
this semester
you know philosophy has a lot of
different subject areas a lot of
different disciplines with that and you
know what we've been doing a lot in this
class is what's called ethics talking
about right and wrong that's the part of
philosophy that deals with that or we've
been talking about what's called
epistemology who actually knows things
who doesn't know things
who should we trust philosophy religion
is concerned with issues like just God
exists or does not you know provide an
argument one way or the other or is
religion and morality religion and
ethics are they connected in some way
that's an issue in the philosophy of
religion and we're going to look at it a
little bit that's an issue that comes up
a lot if you google well if you google
are you going to YouTube and you and you
look up Euthyphro you're not going to
find an awful lot of videos or websites
actually talking about the dialogue
itself what they're going to talk about
is philosophy religion and then what's
called it's not exactly the same he has
what's going on in the text so let's
look at what's going on in the text
first and then let's look at this very
interesting dilemma what Socrates say he
says and I put this for you in that
condensed version yes
issue
who says when I want to first to
understand is whether the pious or the
whole thing is beloved by the gods
because it's holy
or is it holy because it's beloved of
the gods or dear to the gods like the
holy and that's what makes it holy or is
it something that's you know good by
itself and therefore they recognize that
and that's why they like it and this
could work with any thing that you could
think of more broadly think about your
own desires and goods is something good
because you desire it whereas something
desired by you because it's good
sometimes it's one way sometimes it's
the other isn't it how many of you
desire to go to the doctor nobody's a
product what he calls people go to the
doctor all the time
hypochondriac nobody's a hypochondria
you might actually desire to go to the
doctors you get sick somebody you don't
desire it because you know you really
like it it is a good thing though right
going to the doctor every so often get
checked up make sure you're not cancer
what's wrong with you
these things are dissociative you can
you can split them apart desire and
goodness well it's the same way with the
gods and holiness let's say we take any
action like say abortion right let's say
we take unholiness or gods
naugahyde or whatever doesn't like is
abortion something that's wrong because
god doesn't like it because god says
don't do it where does God say don't do
it because it's something bad
these are two different possibilities
and so Socrates says well you know what
is it is the holy beloved by the guys
because it's holy or is this holy
because it's beloved by the guys and he
says so it's love because it it's only
not quality because it's love the gods
love these things because they are in
fact good they're sort of recognizing
the good in it that's what Euthyphro
says and then he says then that which is
dear to the gods is not actually holy
nor is that which is holy loved of or by
God as you affirm it they're two
separate things here's where it gets
really tricky and here's where you may
have been like you know following a walk
so far and then you hit that and said
what the hell is going on here I don't
understand this at all this doesn't make
any sense there's anyone you have that
sort of dislocation anybody have that
happens to me actually every time I read
the dialogue we've got three different
terms
okay and then we've got one buddy guys
pull me and seriously guys okay so let's
think this through
he's saying the holy is love because
it's holy holy because it's long all
right so say X is holy and that's the
reason why you can tell we're you know
we're living in a largely that's what's
going on up there right but then he's
also saying that how do we define holy
let's dear to the guys this is what's
holy so how do we know that's Foley that
is years of Nos therefore X is holy now
here's where it gets really tricky
there's something else being assumed
Socrates is saying this can't be the
same as this because they don't have the
same relationship to being holy is
everybody following that let me say that
again because this is this is a sticking
point these don't have the same
relationship to being holy being dear to
the gods has a different relationship to
being holy than being loved by the gods
has to be importantly what is is causing
the holiness the other one is a clause
of the holiness so they can't be the
same thing now he's not spelling this
out very well this he's just kind of
moving on and you therefore all cap now
it's sort of like you know a boxing
match Uther focus the pop to the face
the surprise and now doesn't know what
to do Uther prose not very good in
arguing if you were very good in
argument you could point out to Socrates
that maybe there's a flaw in the
reasoning here and I'm not going to
actually point out what the flaw the
reasoning is at this point the semester
I'd like you to think about that and
it's a puzzle if you really want it I
will give it to you later on I'll give
you a way in which this could make good
sense but I do want you to puzzle about
it I want you to try to wrap your head
around this and think through it I don't
want to give you all the answers I want
you to try to work out
what does this mean though this means
that youth the first position couldn't
possibly be right so that can't be a
good definition that holiness is that
which is here the guys so that's that's
a what we call it operetta that that's
you know Greek operetta means you get
stuck in someplace and you can't figure
out the right way to get out this is
this is a dialogue full of those sorts
of things let's look at the youth of
this is a little bit different but it's
based on Euthyphro dilemma says either X
is good because God loves it
and the dilemma says we have to pick one
or the other of this so you guys
familiar with this term dilemma you've
all you've all heard it before right so
what is a dilemma it's not just a
problem a little bit more structured to
figure out yeah you can't figure it out
not because you don't understand the
structure but because you don't like
we're either either places going yeah
you don't like we're either either thing
is leading to it so let's look at these
well let's think this is what this means
so if something is good it's good
because God commands it or love it right
so how do you know that abortion is
wrong God says don't do it if God
changes mine tomorrow and said what as
many fetuses as possible then it would
become good right there's a lot of
things and if you think about the Old
Testament there's a lot of Commandments
in there cuz it's not just ten there's
over 600 and some of them you know
really make a lot of sense don't kill
all right that shows up more than once
don't move boundary markers that makes
sense right supposed to actually you
know we don't do that even even in ours
to say you move boundary markers pretty
soon somebody's gonna get a surveyor and
Sue you because it's a bad thing to do
you shall not boil a calf in its
mother's milk that is one of the mitzvot
that's one of the commandments
that one's either in Leviticus
Deuteronomy our numbers nobody's quite
sure what that was but that's actually
the basis for a part of the kosher law
that's why it kosher kitchens meat you
know is kept completely separate from
dairy now what's wrong with mixing meat
and dairy I like a cheeseburger I like
pizza
sausage why do I always got have a
problem with that it's not because of
some intrinsic evil to to sausage pizza
is that because God said so yeah so
that's one end of the dilemma this is
good therefore this is good the other
possibility is why does God say things
are good because they actually are good
and he's just sort of recognizing it's
not his will that makes it good or his
say-so as a matter of fact you could
figure it out on your own without God
maybe here's why why it's a dilemma for
what we call the theist if you again if
you google this where you YouTube this
you'll see the atheists using this as a
sort of wedge against usually against
Christians theists mean people who
believe in God so Christians would be
one branch of theists atheists or those
who don't think I talked about this
before so atheists will say you've got
to pick one side of this and if you pick
this side what's the bad news what's the
bad consequence it looks like morality
then becomes totally arbitrary you know
so I mean if God changed his mind next
week and said then Ten Commandments
thought I was I was actually wrong about
that
I want you to commit adultery then it
would be a requirement and you'd be
wrong you'd be a bad person if you
didn't commit adultery assuming of
course you had a spouse there could be
some preconditions
let's say God said you know ten
commandments isn't enough I think we
need 28 and you start picking stuff like
you will only cross the street at the
crosswalk you will not try to steal home
base if the game is too close you know
things like that it's kind of crazy but
presumably given this this view of the
relationship between morality and
religion that would be one of the
consequences
so that doesn't sound pretty good
doesn't anybody anybody like that you
have a totally arbitrary God don't we
know rules as he or she seems does that
the Greek people follow everything that
we got about everything rather than what
they say is right do they in fact with
them they're supposed to oh yeah it was
supposed to me actually does the pursuit
there be different things I know very
few of theists who seemed to do a very
good job in following what it is that
their faith teaches I include myself
yeah yeah I mean you are supposed to do
if you have some sort of code of morals
you are supposed to follow it the
question here is that where we come from
does it come from God sort of in an
arbitrary manner or is there some sort
of reason so let's say we look at the
second one maybe God commands you you
know to do certain things
certain things because they're actually
bad or good things to do so when God
says don't kill people
maybe it's because God he actually
doesn't want you to kill people because
he thinks people are good
this isn't taking their lives away as
bad you know he's just sort of
recognizing some sort of moral truth
that's out there independent of God yeah
okay so we have free will in order to
decide what we want to do they were
given a command and we can choose
whether to follow it now and this leads
to there's some philosophical issues
again in the philosophy religion we
explore these in much greater detail
we're going to talk about some of this
stuff later on those in this semester
like like will and all that free will
won't get you out of this problem
because this is about where do the where
does the goodness come from where did
the values you can say that free will
apply itself is it good somebody who
were not going to read this semester st.
Augustine and some other people will be
arguably like the ants on the Quietus
think that that free will by itself is a
good thing to have and then we screwed
up but we're given that chance because
giving being given that chances of the
thing but it didn't even with that how
would we know that being given that
chance is a good thing do we need God to
tell us that or could we figure that out
if we thought about it long and hard
enough so here's again where the
atheists would say well like if God
doesn't create what's good and bad
that's not dependent on God what do we
need to got in the picture for at all I
mean or you know let's say we actually
say well we need a minute to get things
started maybe we don't need them
man that's now quick you know quit
messing around just start following them
you know Church just follow the moral
code try to think about what's actually
good event this is what the this is the
dilemma and neither one of these is
really going to work for a theist right
there are some theists who are perfectly
willing to say God is totally arbitrary
I'm gonna follow him no matter what if
he tells me to kill my neighbor that's
gonna be Haiti okay
very few theists actually hold that they
you know nobody wants to say if God
commands me to do something that I
actually think is objectively evil you
would become good because God says so
there are a few but there's there's very
few the theist in general want to say
well there's good and bad and you don't
have to have God to have any sort of
understanding of these if you do there's
not much point in being a thing yes this
is there except maybe you know you like
going to church it's a nice place to
hang out so this is a real dilemma isn't
it it's a real dilemma in the sense that
you can feel its weight and any of the
of you who have come into the class with
some sort of faith I'm not trying to
break you of your faith or anything like
that I don't want you to go home and say
that dr. Sandler did you ruin me for
life through this happening what I'm
saying is this is something that you can
feel the wave though there's a logical
structure to it it does seem like a real
dilemma and it is tied to our reading
there's a way out of it better there
there's several ways out of it
but again I'm not going to tell you what
they are right now I'd like you if you
think this is a real problem I'd like
you to think about this
don't YouTube it don't just go out there
because some of the solutions are out
there on YouTube but I would like you to
actually think about
real issue within the philosophy
religion Arbor reality and religion
connected involved or where can we
totally separate them that's an
important issue for you guys as Booker's
you know does your faith if you have any
faith or other people's faith should
that influence how you do things in
society that's something worth thinking
about so after that detour let's come
back to it's a Euthyphro he tries out a
couple other things so I'm going to run
you through those arguments very quickly
the the next attempt is maybe it's part
of justice upholding the you know what
was justice right and wrong so there
could be a right and wrong way to deal
with human beings right I should treat
you with respect I shouldn't rip you as
you're walking out the door
I should compliment you when you do
something right now there's a right and
wrong way to behave towards the gods
we're death there's a form of justice
with respect to the guts and what does
that mean well this is where Euthyphro
kind of screws up
it means attending to the gods and what
is attending to mean Socrates says he
says well you know when I attend to my
dogs I'm actually doing something to
benefit my dog's like taking care of
them I'm tending to a ship I'm taking
care of the ship how am I taking care of
God does God need me to take care of him
or them or yep presumably I can do just
fine though right
if this guy need any any single one of
you in order to stay God I'm going to be
a healthy gun does God need you to
explain how not to make bad decisions
God did it wouldn't be much of a guy
whether it be something seriously wrong
with the universe so it can't be like
that
so then user for us as well maybe it
means like what slaves do with their
masters that sounds a little bit more
like you know the way religion is often
framed right God's Way up here we're way
down there some some religions answer
that the Babylonian one in the
Babylonian creation story what why are
human beings created it stop it you know
in the image of God or you know to be
companions or anything like that it
workers to be slaves to be slaves of the
guys you know life so the guys they
don't have to fight each other and make
each other slaves because somebody's got
to be a slave that's the Babylonian
so Euthyphro says well maybe it's like
servants and masters but again this is a
problem isn't it if you're somebody's
servant I don't think any of you have
ever been so many servant right you may
have felt like it at times we have this
expression wage slaves have you ever
been wage slaves and I'm working a
dead-end job minimum wage yeah try it
it'll change your perspective in this
quite a bit
why do you real good sense of how much
things you know are worth what we did
when we work for for somebody we're
helping they're not like that what are
we doing we're trying to benefit them
are we does that make sense with God
again I mean benefit God what do we give
God
do we think uh yeah freeze pray it's
okay that's good
the Greeks came sacrifices too we don't
get a lot of sacrifices we might give
some money you know that's the
collection basket around that can be a
sacrifice you can do other sacrifices
too like you know not treating your your
fellow human beings badly because when
you want to prayer right so maybe that
would work maybe it's sort of a
give-and-take
does that work we could take right is
there anything that we could give God
that God really needs that's on his wish
list even the great guns that they need
anything if nobody sacrificed to them
with a with a quitting being gods they
wouldn't like it so this leads us right
back to the starting point
because we had holiness is what's dear
to the gods what can I give the guys
they don't praise honor that sort of
stuff are we helping them by doing that
no so why is that good they like it it
pleases them well we're right back where
we started our way so we've come full
circle and now they happen what does
Euthyphro say
tried out all these different
definitions they haven't figured out
what is they do know but it's not it's
not just doing whatever the gods
happened to do you throw says I gotta
get going
I'd love to stay and chat with you
Socrates